tél
bonjour à tous bienvenue dans europe
hebdo votre rendez vous d'actualité
européenne ici au parlement européen à
bruxelles au programme de cette émission
l'europe face à la menace terroriste
près de six mois après les attentats de
paris en moins après les attentats de
bruxelles comment l'union européenne
peut elle lutter contre ce fléau
alors que le fichier pnr passenger name
record qui doit recenser les
déplacements aériens enfin été votée par
le parlement lors de la dernière session
plénière cet outil sera t-il suffisant
faut-il comme certains le réclament déjà
un fbi à européen
mais d'abord avant d'en débattre avec
mes invités retour sur les ratés des
services de renseignement et de police
dans le cadre de l' enquête a tout de
suite
22 mars 2016 8 heures du matin une
double explosion provoquée par des
kamikazes ravages l'aéroport de
bruxelles zaventem
moins d'une heure plus tard c'est au
tour de la station de métro de malbec à
300 mètres des institutions européennes
bilan 30 personnes décédées plus de 270
blessés fomenté depuis molenbeek et
schaerbeek dans la banlieue de bruxelles
ces attentats plonge la belgique dans
l'horreur quelques mois après les
attentats de paris
ce que nous redoutions s'est réalisé
notre pays et nous concitoyens ont été
frappés
l'enquète détermine rapidement que c'est
la même équipe qui est à l'origine des
deux attentats les arrestations se
succèdent tout comme les révélations sur
les ratés des services de renseignement
face à ce fiasco les ministre belge de
l'intérieur et de la justice ont
présenté leur démission refusée par
charles michel les débats tournent nobel
jm bashing dont la lutte contre le
terroriste dans tous les pays dont le
monde et en europe
il y a eu des succès il ya eu des échecs
il ya eu de grands succès en belgique
nous avons empêché de nombreux attentats
plus de 100 condamnation plus de 100
condamnation l'année passée en un an
en matière de terrorisme concurrence des
services de sécurité nationaux manque de
coopération des renseignements lenteur
des prises de décision les constats sont
les mêmes de bruxelles à paris
probablement qu'il y a encore des
l'amélioration apportée à notre système
de partage d'informations et de
renseignements
face à la menace terroriste les
capitales sont donc condamnés à coopérer
et à s'entendre
et pour en parler je reçois gilles de
kerchove bonjour vous êtes le
coordinateur à la lutte antiterroriste
ici au sein de l'union européenne
bienvenue à vous à côté de vous jean
arthuis vous êtes député européen membre
du groupe libéral démocrate et président
de la commission des budgets bienvenus
bon je vais enfin en face de vos
philippe lambertz vous êtes co président
du groupe des verts ici à dans ce
parlement
messieurs je voudrais d'abord revenir un
petit peu sur cette enquête
comment est ce que vous expliquez à ce
point c'est raté ça a quand même été
pointé un nombre de fois c'est important
que ce soit sur les attentats de paris
puis à bruxelles comment est ce qu'on a
pu à ce point ne pas communiquer entre
nos services gilles de kerchove moi je
trouve que c'est trop tôt pour tirer des
conclusions il y aura des commissions d
enquête qui permettront déterminé moi je
ne tire pas du tout le nécessairement le
la conclusion qui a eu des ratés dans
l'échangeur enseignements si vous
regardez par exemple ce qui s'est passé
à paris avec charlie hebdo est ce que
c'était une un problème de dos n'est pas
nécessairement c'est peut-être que c'est
une question de l'analyse
donc c'est pour moi très important de
dans l'est dans les semaines à venir de
pouvoir tirer les bonnes conclusions
cela étant dit il est clair qu'on doit
intensifier les changes et intensifier
l'analyse vous êtes d'accord
l'épreuve est là j'ai beaucoup de
respect pour gilles de kerchove mais
très franchement quand salades des slam
est arrêté au péage d'hordain et que la
police français lui dit circulez ya rien
à voir
parce qu'elle n'a pas été informé par la
police belge que c'est un suspect d'
actes de terrorisme
j'ai dit il ya quand même un petit
problème de communication la formation
quand el batraoui revient en europe de
turquie que les services turc informe
les services belges et les services
néerlandais attention il ya un gars
dangereux qui est en train de revenir
le type dit non non je veux pas revenir
en belgique c'est trop dangereux je veux
passer par les pays-bas ok fait ça et
sur les trois heures et demie du vol
les hollandais n'ont pas le temps de
dire brin tiens on va peut-être aller le
cueillir et on va le laisser partir en
belgique
qu'on me dise qui est peut-être pas
problème de partage d'informations moi
ça me semble crever les yeux que cette
logique du chacun pour soi à l'intérieur
des états membres les services qui ne
communiquent pas entre eux et entre les
états membres c'est en tout cas un
élément évitant des faillites de la
lutte anti terroriste en europe le
deuxième est évidemment celui et là je
suis assez d'accord avec avec gilles de
kerckhove de l'exploitation
renseignements quand on a dû
renseignement on n'a pas les moyens
moyens
je dis oui jean arthuis c'est un
problème d'homme ou c'est un problème de
volonté politique ça aurait de moyens
oui pas de moyens résulte d'un problème
de volonté politique incontestablement
mais nous sommes dans un espace européen
et le fractionnement de l'espace
judiciaire
c'est le rêve de tous les délinquants de
tous les criminels de tous les
terroristes basques effectivement pour
eux il n'ya pas 28 états ya un seul
territoire et le fait de pouvoir
franchir une frontière pour échapper à
des poursuites
celle idéal pour les délinquants et par
ailleurs l'absence d'échangé
d'informations vous au 21ème siècle
alors que les capacités numériques nous
donne des moyens sans précédent
cette cette attitude des chefs d'état et
de gouvernement parce qu'il reçoive
l'onction démocratique qu'au plan
national à ce qu elle selon vous jean
marc thibault est clair c'est que les
chefs d'état et de gouvernement ne
veulent pas transmettre en fait cette
capacité parce que si on est dans le
domaine du régalien il est hors de
question on ne lâche rien parce que on
veut être celui qui détiendrait les
prérogatives de souveraineté nationale
de karkhov ses moyens en quoi on donne
en spectacle trop souvent l'impuissance
politique c'est ça qui déchaîne le
populisme
on a retrouvé en cherchant un petit peu
dans nos archives et bien une interview
commune qui avait fait gars trader et
jacques chirac
il y a de cela dix ans après les
attentats de londres où déjà à l'époque
il nous parlait d'un esbly européen qui
est revenu donc il y a encore quelques
jours voilà exactement il y a encore
quelques jours dans le débat on réécoute
nous allons renforcer le plan d'action
européen contre le terrorisme nous
l'avons notamment évoqué ce matin nous
allons mieux encore coordonner nos
services de renseignement et de police
et aussi nos justice des camps secrets
je suis d'accord avec le président
chirac
la lutte contre le terrorisme exige que
nous mettions en commun toutes les
énergies nécessaires alors c'est quand
même fou c'était il y a dix ans et on se
retrouve aujourd'hui face à un serpent
de mer qui n'a absolument pas changé
l'eau comme l'antique exactement comme à
rien de bon mais je vous préviens ce qui
s'est fait ces deux finales de 1500 en a
eu chez les cadres la dige de quelques
jours la dit quand bien même on décide
déjà des mesures de partage
d'informations on n'exécute pas et c'est
vrai que vous l'avez vous l'avez dit on
touche au domaine du régalien eux et
donc c'est extrêmement sensible de
strasbourg et villages ans le domaine
trouverez la raison les chefs de
gouvernement et les énormément il ya
évidemment un souci qui est souvent mis
en avant oui mais si on partage les
informations qu'on a et qu'elle tombe
dans de mauvaises mains
parce qu'en fait on n'a pas vraiment une
confiance absolument inébranlable de
l'étanchéité des services de
renseignements de tous les états membres
et je peux comprendre alors on utilise
souvent cet argument là pour dire à
laurent de partage par où l'on prenait
mais là je pense que pour arriver qu'au
plan national on ne partage pas
l'information non plus objectivement il
ya concurrence et on l'a vu en france la
concurrence entre les services gendarmes
police etc
c'est que c'est que les événements qui
sont passés vont produire un sursaut
alors qu'en même temps où l'on voit
jouer simplement dire parce qu'on pose
souvent la question faut-il un billet
européen
honnêtement on peut le regretter mais en
l'état actuel dès textes des traités
l'union n'a pas formellement de
compétences en matière de rendement mais
rien n'empêche de mais parce que c'était
le cadre du mouvement je pense que je
suis assez volontariste mais c'est
possible
de même en sorte que les outils
européens soient alimentés et donc ça
c'est la première ici deuxième exercice
c'est d'encourager les services de
renseignement déjà entre eux
de travailler de manière plus structurée
il travaille entre je crois qu'il faut
pas laisser penser que hatton que que
les services de renseignement ne partage
pas tout vous garantis qu'il travaille
24 heures sur 24 il n'y a pas un chef de
service de renseignement qui est
responsable ils le sont tous qui n'est
pas obsédé par l'idée d'éviter n attends
tu ailles foot quand même sérieux c'est
pas d'urgence c'est pas des gens léger
et il travaille beaucoup
la question n'est pas tellement celle là
c'est plutôt de passer bon ça s'appelle
ça de manière un peu simple de
l'artisanat à l'industrie
mais je dois dire aussi que le club des
services de renseignements je t'avais
qu'il ya quelques jours ils sont en
train de se constituer une plateforme
commune
le défi et sera ensuite en de nouer un
lien entre cette passion commune et
europol ouais et l'a donc du coup jean
arthuis il faut peut-être espérer que ça
vous gêne pas encore 20 ans
salut louis l'engagement de ceux de
kerchove mais vous êtes au service du
conseil
c'est à dire et celle des thèmes
couverts de leur gouvernement et vos
interlocuteurs sont souvent des
diplomates
plus que des politiques ne nous nous
nous sommes par le monde hier et et nous
devons dire avec force et proclamé qui
la nécessité de modifier les traités
maintenant on va pas continuer dans le
cadre mais vous savez elle je veux dire
c'est qu'aujourd'hui le détenteur de la
légitimité de la compétence en matière
de sécurité intérieure celle états
membres on ne va pas aller faire une
robe de la sécurité contre les états
mans il va bien falloir les encourager
et donc je j'approuve asselah proche de
gilles de kerckhove de dire on fait tout
pour encourager sachant qu'il n'y a pas
d'obligation au titre des traités mais
n'y a pas non plus d'interdictions
autrement dit tout ce que les états
veulent faire ensemble rien ne
l'interdît dans les traités donc la
route rien n'oblige donc je vais prendre
l'exemple de repos l'europôle rien
n'était dit europol de recevoir du
renseignement et donc s'il y avait une
volonté politique
europol peut se mettre à recevoir du
renseignement et ils n'ont pas besoin de
s via les rockets un beau la vie ou
alors c'est qu'il n'y a pas d'obligation
dans ce domaine là d'europe est une
obligation d'europe en matière de
schengen
voilà ce qu a pâti moment où vous lever
les contrôles au fonds deviendra
notablement dans les politiques on me
disait
visage est de plus en plus d'assister en
matière de sécurité et c'était mon
raisonnement avec le pnr aussi je disais
au parlement européen joie bièvre vos
objections en matière de vie privée
mais si vous ne le faites pas qu'est ce
qui va se passer tous les états membres
se doter d'un pda nationale
alors pour être clair le pnr un porno
pour nos spectateurs c'est donc un état
fichier qui va recenser 19 informations
votre nom votre prénom le team le bagage
ça peut aller jusqu'à 34 qui est quand
même la plus grosse base de données
potentiellement sur le territoire
européen
donc effectivement ça pose des questions
donc je voulais je suis mort isolement
c'est que si le parlement qui est quand
même une institution supranationale qui
veut pousser à l'intégration aurait eu
comme paradoxe en refusant le pnr
européen qui est pas vraiment européen
on est d'accord mais aurait eu comme
paradoxe qu'on aurait eu 28 peiné à
nationaux veut ça aurait été moins
efficace moins protecteur parce qu'on
sait bien que les niveaux de protection
étaient différents et moyse européen ce
corps était tout de même un paradoxe
alors justement à ce propos le plr a
donc été voté la semaine dernière après
des mois d'atermoiements voire des
années est ce que ça va changer quelque
chose d'avoir ce fichier est ce que cela
va véritablement empêché de nouveaux
attentats terroristes en ouvrant le pnr
et arrêtons de parler du pnr il s'agit
bien de 28 pnr un standard européen
peut-être mais c'est le jour 28 pb alors
dire le pnr 28 pnr dans lesquelles entre
lesquels les échanges d'information
n'est pas obligatoire première chose
d'eux on nous vend l'outil comme un
outil d'identification d'accord or moi
je regardais faits et les faits nous
disent eh bien ça fait dix ou quinze ans
que des attentats se commettent par des
gens qui sont identifiés pour l'immense
majorité d'entre eux ils sont identifiés
se sont pas des nouveaux venus
le pnr dans le cas dans les cas qui nous
occupe aurait servi à rien du tout et
donc moi je pose une question à gilles
de kerckhove que je n'ai pas toujours
entendus enthousiaste du pn et qu'est ce
qui nous empêcherait d'avoir un système
de collecte
ciblez vous détournent à 5000 suspect
donc qu'est-ce qui nous empêcher d'avoir
un système de collecte ciblées et sous
mandat judiciaire de donner un peu d'air
avec ça moi j'ai aucun problème
ce qu'on a maintenant c'est une collègue
généralisée et sans contact ça c'est pas
on appelle ça va évidemment de très 540
être puissant charles ont parlé des
moyens humains comment est-ce qu'on
traite autant de données jean arthuis
technique est accusée mais vous en prie
moi j'ai voté le pnr
mais c'est un couteau sans manche en
effet ses 28 ans à mes nerfs il ya le
feu dans la maison mais les états
membres disposent de deux ans pour
mettre en application cette directive
l'échangé d'information n'est pas une
obligation alors néanmoins il offre une
possibilité de coopération entre
certains états membres et simplement
qu'exemple j'espère et que certains
parmi eux vont s'en saisir ce qui est
une confiance mutuellement en eux
puisque on me dit que dans certains cas
on ne veut pas changer automatiquement
parce qu'il pourrait y avoir des fuites
d'informations donc au moins il ya
quelques états sûr et j'espère que ce
ces états là vont pouvoir travailler
rapidement sans parce que si on laisse
chacun développé son propre logiciel et
y aura-t-il une parfaite compatibilité
le jour de vos relations
vin très vite revenir avec une mesure
d'application de la directive en
définissant des standards communs donc
je pense que techniquement ce sera pas
tellement le problème il faut bien
comprendre à quoi sert le pn et le pn et
ce n'est pas la solution à tout je pense
que si quelqu'un a dit ça il y aura
toujours de quoi c'est la solution en
fait c'est pour pouvoir détecter les
mouvements suspects de personnes qu'on
n'aurait pas détecté à travers le
travail durant ces demandes terrain
c'est à dire que à molenbeek ou dans les
banlieues françaises
une mêlée de renseignement arrive à
détecter à travers leur travail normal
des gens qui se dirige vers la syrie et
demain ça peut être un os est allé à la
pêche dont ils le font leur travail de
terrain
ah non je dirais qu'il ya plus ou moins
30% qu'on ne parvient pas à détecter
nous avons maintenant nous allons
changer législation pour contrôler
systématiquement les européens mais en
fait le pnr sert à quoi
sur la base de ce que nous dit le
renseignement sur le profil moyen à
mardi du profiling c'est une sorte de
profiling mais absolument je ne devais
pas de gêne aldi mais vous savez que
julio mis ça pour effet de réduire le
profiling et je dirais le contrôle
ethnique pourquoi parce qu'on ne se base
pas sur la couleur de la peau on se bat
non sans religion mais on se base sur
des conneries je dois expliquer si je ne
considère pas que c'est nécessairement
l'équité mais s'il les services de
renseignements vous dise le candidat
moyens et qui par an en eau-de-vie adore
en syrie c'est quelqu'un qui voyageaient
sans bagage prend son billet le dernier
jour est payant cash par exemple vous
mettez ces trois indicateurs qui sont
franchement anodin on a bien l'accord et
vous les mettez dans votre algorithmes
et vous peignez des milliers de
passagers
vous sortez simplement la liste de ceux
qui ont plus ou moins ce profil là
ce qui ne veut pas dire qu'on les arrête
ça veut dire simplement que la la police
s'y intéresse
on travaille mais on s'y intéresse le
type à la frontière à votre avis fait
quoi quand il voit passer des flux à la
tête du client
et bien justement ça réduit cette espèce
d'argot falling maintenant et donc ça me
paraît déjà très longue éclipse
rationnellement ça a l'air de tenir la
route maintenant les etats-unis ont un
pnr or je sais qu'au congrès des états
unis
on demande au département de l'intérieur
tient au fait afin de la sécurité
intérieure tiens le pnr ça c'est bien
quelque chose et jusque maintenant la
réponse est pas vraiment il avait un
exemple s'il avait un exemple où grâce à
du profiling il ait pu empêcher un
attentat je suis sûr qu'il serait sorti
alors à l'agitée avec un grand dans la
pauvreté
ces derniers mois qu'ils ordinaire c'est
un instrument ça n'est pas forcément la
solution
c'est un début de réponse mais c'est pas
ça il va nourrir la logique c'est on
collecte des informations sur tout le
monde on fait tourner dessus des
algorithmes pour identifier les
comportements déviants contre le
terrorisme dit bah oui c'est bien normal
quand nos données sortie avec la
surveillance généralisée des
télécommunications d'internet etc
on s'est tous dit skandal scandale en
fait c'est exactement la même logique
qui est allé arracher les grandes forêts
les procès sont les connaît donc si on
ne prétend pas à régler tous les
problèmes
c'est un instrument supplémentaire peut
créer avec ça je viens de poser très
clairement le principe d'un mba
européens il ya dix ans à monsieur
fraudeurs et monsieur chirac
on était les promoteurs il s'est rien
passé depuis donc j'espère que cette
situation de dramatique cette tragédie
qui met de nos opinions publiques en
transe j'espère que politiquement en
vain tiré les conséquences et met donc
là moi je propose puisque nous n'avons
pas juridiquement les compétences de le
faire dans le cadre institutionnel de
l'union en tant que fbi aux censeurs
recueil de renseignements monsieur renzi
il a proposé monsieur michel l'a proposé
rien empêché états membres allait
radicalement coopération structurée et
il faut vous savez quand europol a été
créée vous savez comment ça s'est passé
c'est le chancelier kohl à la suite de
la chute du mur de berlin qui était très
préoccupé par la criminalité en
provenance de russie et il a contre
l'avis de son bk arrêt contre l'avis de
son ministre de l'intérieur parce que
c'était un homme qui avait dit leader
ship dont la négociation de maastricht
il a dit nous allons le faire
personne ne savait ce que c'était at on
l'acceptait pâlissante haricots et ça se
trouve alors une autre
il ya eu une autre conséquence à ces
attentats c'est le retour des contrôles
aux frontières a notamment la frontière
franco belge
on a voulu savoir un petit peu comment
se déroulaient ces contrôles renforcés
donc cia et le goujon qui s'est rendu
sur place
de mémoire de chauffeurs routiers on
n'avait pas vu ça depuis 20 ans ici
c'est souvent 20 à 30 minutes qu'on perd
à cause des embouteillages dus au
rétrécissement des voies pour passer la
frontière sous l'oeil des douaniers
français partiront depuis le
rétablissement des contrôles à la
frontière franco belge
le trafic routier est ralentie des
kilomètres de bouchons et au bout une
fouille aléatoire des cargaisons une
entorse à la libre circulation des
marchandises
les accords de schengen ont été signés
il ya maintenant 20 ans cette pme de
transport belge a vu son chiffre
d'affaires ça fléchir de 5% l'impact
pour nous disons que vous voyez qu'un
chauffeur problè entre 9 et 10 heures 2
heures de travail qui perd à peu près
une demi heure par jour ça fait à peu
près de 5% environ 5 % de perte de
chiffre d'affaires ce restaurant routier
lui perd beaucoup plus ici les clients
ont déserté reste les voisins et les
habitués les routiers sont un peu trop
occupés à passer la douane
le midi ils en veulent beaucoup de monde
mais maintenant c'est avec la bouche on
il a beau temps de s'arrêter après les
contrôles au qe2
les heures de route et les aires de
repos ce putsch à 7 est calme maintenant
rétablissement de la frontière dans la
foulée des attentats de novembre à paris
les contrôles se sont accentuées au fil
des semaines crise migratoire
abbas ali
t il
ont resserré le long des six cent vingt
kilomètres de frontière nous sommes à
warneton
de l'autre côté du pont la belgique si
les forces de l'ordre ne peuvent pas
tout contrôler et qu'il n'a jamais été
question de fermer les frontières carte
grise assurance est permis de conduire
les contrôles sont plutôt tatillon vous
pouvez ouvrir votre coffre aussi
l'opinion va vous passez officier du
couple permis de conduire comme vous
avez pas en cinq mois près de 6 millions
de personnes ont dû montrer patte
blanche à l'entrée en france et dix
mille se sont vus interdites de
territoire
certaines personnes étaient signalées
par les fiches est ce que nous faisons
en sorte aussi d'avoir des contrôles
avec un nombre suffisant de gendarmes
des gendarmes qui sont armés d'armes de
pistolets mitrailleurs pour être en
mesure de faire face à la menace qui est
aujourd'hui un niveau très élevé si du
côté français on affiche une volonté de
faire du côté belge on est moins
optimiste c'est toute la frontière
franco belge
faux garçons précis
à longue échéance est pas possible à
court terme bon alors oui sinon c'est
pas fort
en tout il existe mille 500 points de
passage entre les deux pays
alors quand on leur pose la question les
habitants sont plutôt sceptiques sur
l'intérêt du dispositif
donc ils vont sur les grosses frontières
oui c'est sûr que c'est rassurant mais
je pense que quelqu'un qui veut passer
la frontière ils peuvent sans problème
il ya trop de comment dire la frontière
est trop large donc on peut on sait pas
mettre des gens d'un peu partout je
pense pas donc au voeu au final celui
qui prépare bien son plan pour passer la
frontière pour les attentats je pense il
peut passer quoi honnêtement c'est ce
que je pense
routes autoroutes village mêmes canaux
la gendarmerie multiplie les modes
opératoires
ce qu'on recherche c'est le type de
trafic donc sa lutte antiterroriste
comme et trafic de stupéfiants notamment
pour le transport de personnes
marchandises à fait crucial c'est aller
un des vecteurs de mettre votre
confiance votre destination votre
chargement et le nombre de personnes
l'équipage
mais avec 60 contrôle par mois les
canaux reste un point de passage discret
je n'ai pas de contrôle
on passe au big boi thales a pas changé
pour les bateaux ça va changer
cependant l'or comme en belgique
beaucoup de contrôles en france en mai
au final surveiller les frontières est
il toujours une bonne stratégie
le lendemain des attentats salle
abdeslam et contrôlée par trois fois
avant de traverser la frontière
le tout sans être inquiété
alors philippe lambert je voyais à qui
est cependant ce reportage diriez vous
que la frontière franco belge est une
véritable passoire gruyère finalement
qu'on est dans de la communication non
je me rappelle juste après les attentats
de novembre à paris nous avions session
à strasbourg et la france avaient décidé
de fermer ses frontières et en effet il
y avait un barrage filtrant à la
frontière luxembourgeoise et donc pour
le retour je me suis dit je vais pas
passer par là j'ai passé par longwy est
là et donc c'était quatre jours après le
début de la session donc on n'est pas le
terrain leur dit on est revenu un jeudi
et donc il y avait absolument rien ça va
on vous fermez stations de métro ont
fait entre
camélia personne pour contrôler dans
toute façon tout le monde s'en fout pays
fassent idée que en mettant un gendarme
tous les dix mètres on va prévenir les
attentats je crois que c'est c'est un
petit peu une illusion savez il ya un
état qui surveille ses citoyens
massivement physiquement
électroniquement c'est la chine
ce qu'est ce qu'on observe qu'il ya des
attentats suicide en chine aussi donc se
dire que la sécurité absolue on va
l'avoir grâce à ça c'est pas vraiment si
vous êtes d'accord
je pense que lorsque se produisent des
attentats et des drames que l'opinion
publique est en émoi et les pouvoirs
publics procèdent à des actions de
communication donc cela pour vous les
dents de la communication clairement on
voit circuler dans les rues de bruxelles
des engins blindés
hormis la frontière mais très
franchement on est dans la communication
le vrai sujet c'est que quand on a créé
l'espace schengen les états membres ont
tiré les bénéfices de l'opération c'est
à dire qu'ils sont supprimer des postes
douaniers
ceci a permis quelques fois de faciliter
le rééquilibrage relatif des budgets
mais on sait pas du tout préoccupé des
frontières extérieures voilà on appris
en a pris les dividendes de la
suppression des frontières intérieures
et on s'est pas occupé du reste c'est là
qu'il ya une sorte de deux bévues
collective et on a dit voilà au nom de
la souveraineté nationale sont
responsables ceux des états qui ont des
frontières extérieures
alors si ça vient par la grèce eh bien
c'est la grèce qui est responsable
et si ça vient par l'italie c'est
l'italie qui est responsable à la res
promet des collaborateurs à disposition
ils sont sous l'autorité de la grèce par
exemple on envoie des douaniers français
en grèce ils sont sous l'autorité du
gouvernement alors j'ai le gars comme on
est on est au milieu du gué là avec
schengen l'espace et il ya eu des
bénéfices pour les états est le bénéfice
pour l'économie c'est que tu as fait un
formidable développement économique qui
s'en dit henry
je ne conteste pas je dis simplement
qu'on n'a pas mis en place aux
frontières extérieures les moyens
appropriés s'avère un peu théorique mais
j'ai bien rappeler aussi qu'au fond
schengen c'est pas la libre circulation
des personnes paradoxalement schengen
c'est un projet de mesures
compensatoires lalibela liberté de
circulation étaient prévues par les
traités communautaires
on se fait schengen et c'est un projet
qui ne s'arrêtera jamais il faut le dire
il faut et quand je dis il faut plus de
chaînes y est ça veut dire plus de
mesures de contrôle aux frontières
extérieures donc tout temps de la corse
mais les frontières intérieures donc ça
veut bien dire que la leur établissement
la frontière franco-belge eux c'est
absurde sérieux mais c'est en étant
beaucoup plus vigilant en frotter
l'extérieur 6 jeux thématiques
la commission a fait la proposition de
contrôler systématiquement les citoyens
européens parce que nous avons gelé 10 à
1000 à l'entraînement oui mais c'est
déjà un progrès parce que pour le moment
ce n'était pas le cas
et aussi la transformation de frontex en
un système de garde frontières européens
avec la possibilité de se substituer un
état qui ne rempliraient pas les alors
l'instant mais pour l'instant ça c'est
l'état est ainsi à la frontière vers une
mutualisation c'est un processus qui
prend du temps et il faut tout le temps
raffinés se mesure qu'on pense à toi
c'est aussi l'échangé d'informations par
exemple en matière de renseignement
c'était peut-être les deux des mesures
compensateur schengen qui étaient les
moins développés et donc on va vers là
et ça ne s'arrêtera pas parce que la
criminalité va peut-être encore se
transformer méchante kaka vous qui êtes
du côté du conseil
la commission a mis sur la table une
proposition pour des gardes-côtes pour
des gardes-frontières sous quelle
autorité seront ils et quelle est
l'attitude du conseil en la circonstance
pour l'instant il n'y a pas de réponse
moi j'attends que on est une position
claire de la part du conseil sur une
question d'ego ciation lâché dans les
négociations mais on n'en finit pas
alors est-ce qu'on a tendance à voudrait
dire qu'il faut rétablir quoi qu'il
arrive les frontières aux fins dans
schengen les frontières intérieures je
ne peux être que temporaire c'est pour
une période limitée
s'il ya vraiment dans juifs et là en
l'occurrence devant la menace de death
est ce qu'il faudrait pas enfin la
période aux frontières entre les états
membres
c'est la vigilance à l'hôtel il va
falloir aussi qu'on apprenne à vivre
avec la menace la menace terroriste
le risque zéro n'existera pas aussi que
c'est là qu'ils ont fait ici on peut
être cru par nos concitoyens il faut pas
leur vendre du vent de l'air les faits
je suis assez d'accord avec jean arthuis
quand il y beaucoup d'action
dites de sécurité sont des actions de
communication et les citoyens réalisent
bien parce qu'il le voit sur le terrain
par contre je crois que nous devons
faire tout ce qui est en notre pouvoir
pour collecter les informations dont on
a besoin surtout les exploitent et moi
je suis un peu inquiet quand je vois
qu'on va aller
m un demi milliard dans les 28 pnr quand
on sait la pauvreté de la police de
proximité souvent c'est le renseignement
de terrain qui va faire la différence
et là dessus on a désinvesti quand même
dans tous les états membres de moyens
humains ils le cachent mal moi je suis
totalement d'accord
donc là je suis aussi d'accord qu'il
faut bien envoyé le message la
population que le risque zéro n'existe
pas mais sur le travail de terrain moi
je les encourage c'est pas simplement la
police de proximité se gérer tous les
tous les acteurs de première ligne et
formés à détecter par exemple
destination pour apporter des réponses
non sécurité voilà des jeunes
oui c'est à faire de la prévention alors
toutes mes interventions
il fait toujours à volet sécurité mais
j'insiste énormément sur le volet de
prévention kfy là on doit faire beaucoup
plus a supposé moyens et pour l'instant
les moyens où sont les finances cdf
plupart des états membres
c'est un vrai sujet et dont la faible
ils sont pas nos économies en fermant
les frontières intérieures et bien ce
sera le mot de la fin messieurs de la
vigilance merci merci à vous d'avoir
accepté de débattre sur cette question
voilà c'est la fin de cette émission
vous pouvez l'avoir bien entendu sur
notre site internet vous pouvez réagir
et commenter sur les réseaux sociaux la
semaine prochaine vous retrouver ahmed
tazir ici à cette place ciao